[Music]
here on the things we'd love to discuss
everything about Disney so no wonder we
had to explore what Disney Princesses
would look like in alternate universes
can you guess which Hogwarts house mulan
got into give this video a thumbs up if
you want us to cover more disney topics
and don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel
today we're exploring ten Disney
Princesses and alternate universes Ariel
as a pirate if there ever was a Disney
Princess he would probably do well as a
pirate it would definitely be Ariella
get it okay let's just move on the
sixteen year old little mermaid doesn't
look that little anymore
she's now dressed in an awesome pirate
costume move over Elizabeth Swann
there's a new pirate princess on the
horizon this pirate Ariel was
illustrated by the very talented artist
called yin thei Ariel looks like she's
certainly ready for the ship life all
the while looking unbelievably stylish
apart from her long red hair we're
totally loving the blue skirt and the
blouse with white sleeves do you think
area would be able to handle the famous
Jack Sparrow and his crew now that would
be an alternate universe we'd love to
see did you know that it was once common
to think that having a female pirate
aboard could cause your ship bad luck
but that didn't stop the woman from
getting dressed as men and showing
everyone that you can be a pirate and a
woman at the same time does it sound
familiar perhaps there's another
princess who would be perfect for the
pirate role but more about her later she
got sorted into Hogwarts stay tuned to
find out which house she got into
Pocahontas as Selena
no not Selena Gomez many people are
still madly in love with the late selena
quintanilla the popular singer was and
still is an inspiration to many who are
trying to make it into the music
industry her success put Mexican
American music on the map and her songs
are still cherished to this day so it's
only reasonable Disney Princesses pay a
tribute to this iconic singer with such
a tragic story
here's Pocahontas as Selena created by
Isiah Stephens who's arrgh you can also
see in some of our other videos Isaiah
is a self-confessed Selena fan and he
loved the idea of redesigning Disney
Princesses into the life of Selena he
said each drawing took him anywhere
between two to eight hour
to finish but as you can see his work
paid off Pocahontas
definitely looks like she's ready to be
on the cover of a magazine Selena was so
iconic someone actually made a petition
to really turn Selena into a Disney
Princess how cool is that although she
might no longer be with us the spirit of
the queen of Tejano music still lives on
we'd love to see Disney Princesses cover
some of Selena's songs we can totally
see Pocahontas covering Selena's
dreaming of uhit Merida as Katniss
Everdeen when it comes to Hunger Games
mixed with Disney we can only think of
one princess who could play the part of
Katniss Merida seems like she could very
well become the next Katniss Everdeen
this Merida was designed by deviant art
user Portia Geum and we're absolutely in
love with this picture this form users
set up an interesting scenario to see
which of the two iconic characters would
win in a battle place both Merida and
Katniss in a forest to hunt each other
they both get a bow and only ten arrows
who would win we're giving this trophy
to the queen of archery Merida don't
forget she managed to split her own
arrow with another one as much as we
love Katniss we really do think Merida
wouldn't have any competition at all if
she'd ever competed in The Hunger Games
we are sure she'd even volunteer as a
tribute to replace one of her little
brothers but the question on our minds
is would she be team Peeta or Gale or
would love not be one of the important
themes in this version of The Hunger
Games after all Merida is one of the few
Disney Princesses that don't need a
significant other in their story Moana
as Wonder Woman whether Moana is a
Disney princess or not is a subject of
long debate but remember wood Maui's
said about the definition of a princess
if you wear a dress and have an animal
sidekick europe princess this is why
we're putting Moana on the list Moana is
one of the most revolutionary female
Disney characters yet and it's no wonder
she has taken the world by storm
she might have not been around for a
long time but that didn't stop some
hardcore Disney fans from putting Moana
in an alternate universe with their
drawing skills Moana as the Wonder Woman
is the artwork of the very talented
deviant art user Darth Rayner 83 if you
thought Moana was already an amazing
character this
illustration will blow your mind Wonder
Woman Emma wanna actually share a few
common traits including their awesome
hair which took the creators of Moana a
lot of time to perfect
and don't forget Wonder Woman is also a
princess on her own
speaking of Disney Princesses and
alternate universes did you know that
flounder from The Little Mermaid
actually made a cameo in Moana can you
find him in this picture
Belle as a man by now you're probably
thinking about creating your own
versions of Disney Princesses in
alternate universes make sure you let us
know your ideas in the comments have you
ever wondered what Disney Princesses
would look like if they became men check
out Belle no lipstick no eyeliner short
hair just a little bit bushier eyebrows
and voila Belle could easily play both
genders a Canadian illustrator that goes
by the name of psyche me chin took this
image to the next level an even better
level not only is Belle a man the beast
is a girl this talented illustrator
really knows their stuff check out the
amazing detail on this photo which also
proves that men totally Rock long hair
we love how Belle's blue and white dress
became what looks like a blue vest a
white shirt and blue pants and the Beast
he definitely gives off girly vibes
perhaps it's the way how his claws touch
his hair or his Beach style hair no
longer tied back in a ponytail we are
loving this illustration did you know
that Belle's dress is blue because it
symbolizes active strength her blue
dress also made her completely different
from others in her town no one was
wearing the same color jasmine as a
pokemon trainer I want to be the very
best like no one ever was a very fitting
theme song for some of our Disney
Princesses right Jasmine showed us that
women can be equally as powerful as men
but would she be able to go up against
some of the biggest Pokemon trainers and
show them who's the boss
Disney mixed with Pokemon is the world
we'd love to see and here she is dressed
as a pokemon trainer and ready for
action
she's wearing her signature blue collar
with the top slightly modified to fit in
the world of Pokemon how cute is this
here's another image showing what
Jasmine would look like in the Pokemon
world this illustration was created by
the very talented deviant-art user black
wolf 6 4 5 look at that jazz
Mena's cuddling Pidgey who by the way
doesn't really seem to be enjoying this
little love fest and for the little
cherry on top
here's another bonus picture of jazmine
in the Pokemon world this time with ash
on the magic carpet by Aladdin this
image was created by Kurumi Erica from
deviant art which Pokemon do you think
Jasmine would have make sure you let us
know in the comments below
the flying Pidgey seems to be a very
appropriate choice Snow White has hope
now here's a combination you never think
would work but for some strange reason
it just does
Snow White looking mighty and definitely
scary as half full so how would that
work exactly The Hulk also known in his
human form as Robert Bruce Banner was a
completely different character than snow
white with much bigger problems he
turned into the Hulk every time he got
angry but what could possibly anger the
gentle and somewhat shy Snow White to
turn her into such a muscular monster
this fascinating picture was illustrated
by the talented Christopher Stoll who
created a whole series of photos with
Disney princesses in the world of
Avengers but we're particularly
impressed with this angry looking Snow
White don't stand in her way it's
probably not a very good idea we love
how she's still sporting the cute red
hair bow her signature hair and whatever
is left of her beautiful dress her blue
shoulder top seems to work just fine
with the Hulk's big muscles these
drawings definitely make us jealous of
these princesses as well as the fact
that some people are just capable of
creating such awesome art with just a
few illustration tools and their
imagination Mulan at Hogwarts so we
looked at what Disney Princesses would
look like as pirates Latin superstar
Selena Hunger Games participants
adventures and Pokemon masters what's
missing if you're a huge Harry Potter
fan
you probably analyze which Hogwarts
house people belong in don't worry we do
this to we're pretty sure we be sorted
in Hufflepuff have you ever wondered
which house would a disney princess be
sort event will them IJ in 1991 from
deviantART certainly has and they gave
us all the answers we were looking for
if you guess Gryffindor your Hogwarts
house just won 100 points
is probably the textbook example of
someone who would be long in the
Gryffindor House she has no problem with
getting herself into potential danger if
it meant protecting the person she loves
does it sound like another Gryffindor
you know and hold on wait a second is
that a raccoon Patronus or is she just
channeling her inner Pocahontas we think
Mulan would definitely achieve some
great things at Hogwarts Disney mixed
with a Harry Potter world yes please is
there a Disney princess you would put in
Slytherin all Disney Princesses as a
single princess we're almost done guys
it's time for the two more fascinating
pictures of Disney princesses and
alternate universes that completely blew
us away so what would happen if you put
all Disney Princesses together and
created a single princess character if
you thought it was impossible to do this
and turn it into something amazing
get ready to have your mind blown this
amazing illustration was drawn by
Kristen Webb who also creates awesome
coloring books for children and adults
check this out how many Disney
Princesses can you spot we see Merida
Ariel jasmine Snow White Cinderella and
Rapunzel each color or the dress
represents a different princess and you
can probably spot even more princesses
once you check out the hair and
accessories can you tell who the blue
and the yellow shoe belong to and the
white braid this definitely shows that
Disney Princesses really know how to
accessorize and no those aren't gold
horns coming out of this princess's face
it's Jasmine's earrings we can even spot
Tiana's flower dress this truly is the
best of both worlds this princess story
and personality would probably be even
more complex than any Disney character
we've ever seen Disney sleepover but
what's even better than having all
princesses together in a single princess
seeing all of them hang out in the same
room and have a sleepover now this is
definitely an alternate universe we can
never experience Disney characters have
been another disney movies before you
could find the beast in Aladdin
Aladdin's magic carpet and Princess and
the Frog and so on so on but most Disney
princesses never made secret cameos and
other stories than their own maybe for
an obvious reason but it's a movie we
would love to see check out this
photo made by an Instagram user pasta
left isn't it the cutest there is Ariel
Rapunzel Pocahontas Mulan
Tiana Jasmine and Elsa and is that
Aurora the Sleeping Beauty on Pocahontas
mug we are in love with their ones use
their dresses their animal sidekicks
Rapunzel's hair is so long all girls
could probably take a few parts to braid
it this looks like it could be the berry
best sleepover ever
what do you think they're talking about
their princes are they watching Disney
movies gossiping about other princesses
we'll probably never find out but a
Disney summer party would be one of the
most interesting Disney movies ever
come on Disney make it happen which
Hogwarts house do you think Disney
Princesses belong in let us know in the
comments below don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up if you're a huge
disney fan for even more disney
extravaganza check out 15 disney
princesses reimagined by amazing artists
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]